Klingon easy son
hi I'm Eric singer Eric is a dialect
coach and guy who really loves
linguistics today we're going to talk
about constructed languages conlangs are
languages that have been made up by a
person rather than being a naturally
occurring language that's evolved over
time we're going to start with six big
conlangs cinder in junior art Tolkien's
Lord of the Rings
Kevon nothing winning how they don't
know yet Navi from the movie avatar of
course Klingon from Star Trek aged or
German we've been got monkey
Parseltongue from Harry Potter and
Dothraki but Moe where they are being in
high Valyrian from Game of Thrones
yeah what's game or lux you've stepped
us and if you stick around we'll get to
some other random stuff well should I go
metalloid part one conlangs let's begin
with Parseltongue Harry Potter so one of
the cool things about Parseltongue of
course is that snakes have different
Anatomy from people they don't have lips
so we don't get sounds using the lips
like Papa mmm they don't have vocal
folds right so everything is unvoiced
and also because snakes hiss
a lot of the sounds get lengthened so we
get that means leave him alone or go
away cuz you know he's telling the snake
to go away and that last sound that
which you may recognize from arabic that
constricted what we call a pharyngeal
fricative which is a fancy term for your
throat your pharynx is constricting a
little bit we have that in Parseltongue
because snakes like to constrict things
I just became Parseltongue you had me
one of the natural language inspirations
for Parseltongue was knee-jerk Congo
languages which have pairs of vowels one
version of which has your tongue root
pushed forward oh oh oh Coco and one has
your tongue root pulled back oh oh oh
Chee and it has finished vowel harmony
spoke a different language daniel
radcliffe as I don't know a ten-year-old
that's doing it pretty well I'm
impressed but I didn't realize it Kahn
laying to Klingon from Star Trek Klingon
hole that Chuck
so Klingon was made up by Marc Okrand
hi my name is Marc to sound not like any
actual human language of course they're
human actors speaking it so he had to
use sounds that exist in human languages
they have a really strange set of
distributions sort of the three basic
elements in a sentence or the subject
the verb and the object Klingon has a
really unusual word order very small
percentage of human languages put the
object of a sentence first then the verb
then the subject that mathematically
there's six of these things so the book
to him gave I where we would say I gave
him the book or I gave the book to him
pretty much like Yoda dr. King gave ride
that's he o to speak obviously Klingon
was meant to sound kind of harsh and
guttural and warlike it has a lot of
sounds using the back of the vocal tract
and the throat things like coal and hot
Sheldon in the Big Bang Theory does a
pretty nice version of this actually
botas be djibouti rick that sound is a
very enthusiastic uvular affricate in
the sentence revenge is a dish best
served cold
what is wrong with you or literally when
told revenge is served it is always very
good what means is very good so that
word shop looky shop looky he doesn't
get that that tongue tip curl back d
sound that yeah yeah so it should be job
blue d like an Indian or South Asian
language does does does require I think
greater concentration so the
english-speaking actors who speak
Klingon often don't really do that
tongue tip curled all the way back
listen to this oh so you can hear in
that very last word who cloade
and it should be just sound which Worf
just doesn't do either Lord just hearing
a regular kind of English Lord Lord
guess who gets this pretty close to
being right I'll keep this short
Frasier pull off Lord we let go oh and
that ya sound at the end poor lord is
pretty close that's not gibberish eats
Klingon but but this is one of my
favorite sounds it's what's called a
voiceless alveolar lateral Africa TL
sound but without any voicing so claw
it's a sound you can find in Navajo
Lizzie bendy hiss no and in Lincoln yeah
that was very good and you can hear her
say it twice here in Porto Box mo bak
bak the combi buck means honor in
Klingon which is a very important word
to Klingons obviously colbry Bonjour
chuckling Jane so she's saying you and
your people are in danger and that sure
sure
it's like an English SH sound but again
it's retroflex like duck so the tongue
tip is curled back and good so you can
hear that sound in Russian but yet it
Afeni it Mandarin Chinese that's what
someone - you said you heard that
haha sound hole hey push the sock is a
really popular sound in conlangs it's
pretty familiar from Scottish like Loch
Ness no look I am as well tonight it's
in Valyrian my foot Grayson you can hear
it in Dothraki Drogo
so Klingon has a vocabulary thousand
words which is a lot new ones keep being
added because it's been around for a
while there about a hundred fluent
speakers of Klingon many more who can
speak a little bit put you can take
tests and exams for proficiency Klingon
coal holds more weight do oh did you
know that there is a Klingon translation
of Hamlet to be done or not
bah bah and in question Baku care Bombay
Shh Klingon has improved over time in
terms of actors getting the sounds right
listen to this you vote now doc pick vom
dach
sure yeah I supposed to this horse kick
a George vet so new Khan Lane three high
valyrian Game of Thrones doctor sigelei
a out game Alex your depth us screen
Kanta
this upon Toledo hexa said you mozu
Thoreau says Crete Gupta and that first
sound made at the very back of the mouth
it's called a uvula plosive that's a
sound that's all over natural languages
although not really in any European or
Western languages huh here's that same
sound in Klingon of course this is a big
world the characters who speak high
Valyrian come from all different places
and they speak different dialects ah
Valley real moon Ewing was new he sees
it high Valyrian proper there's a
ballast on you which you can hear in
this clip right here in the cortex leads
to loose that's the same sound you hear
in French - juniper - no it's basically
an e sound with the lips rounding
forwards E E so now you can make the
difference in French between Q and two
sometimes Melisandre pronounces the
sound that's supposed to be that as an e
sound over C that is ehehehe which
mostly actors on the show do most of the
time but of course they all speak
different dialects in ancient proper
high Valyrian it was always you
refrigerator speak high Valyrian high
Valyrian is a little bit like Estonian
winter not my bachelor - I mean Russian
Adama motivating Pharaoh's skit Swahili
na lang gonna equal own Alyoshka
and kind of like Latin everything what
is that the very it is is this ancient
language in this world Khan laying for
Dothraki Game of Thrones the king of
Azshara mama Cueva affin mori Hakeem I
in that line what you saying something
like I will give to him a golden crown
that men will tremble when they see it
you hear a wave a wave it that's that
uvula plosive coil which means will
tremble it's the future tense of kovat
which is to tremble
some people think Dothraki sounds
like Arabic if I had thought of most
edit on Surya its natural language
influences or more from Turkish mythos
Jakarta novice is Russian thank you yeah
so he Lee you know nominee Rama is my
person and a neuticle
American being a SEMA Yuna here's Johnny
American English has a really weird R
sound this thing that you do when you
bunch up your tongue
oh right either this is a really weird
sound it barely exists in any other
language on earth and it's a weird thing
to do with your tongue so it's often
really hard both for kids to acquire say
oh yes takes until about five yeah it's
hard for non-native speakers so it gets
left out of conlangs because it also
just kind of sounds like American
English good one really popular approach
is to have a tapped are like in an
old-fashioned British now is the winter
of our discontent glorious summer bedded
here you can hear it in high Valyrian
Susie Lyra GBA Dothraki job or severe
Barack Klingon Lin moogly interestingly
Valyrian has the same contrast Spanish
does two different eye sounds which can
change the meaning of a word one is a
tap
duh and fatal yeah there's a trill or
rolling are in federal different word
only one different sound
Dothraki has sometimes a tap sometimes a
trill it doesn't actually make a
difference in the meaning of the word
here it's trill Yeti was edgy diva diva
I used linguistic evolution as a
characterization tool basically giving
insight into the history of the speakers
so Khal Drogo is a native speaker of
Dothraki and it sure seems like he is
even though it's a made-up language also
the excessive heed or my booty check out
there Daenerys is learning it down on
that I got to everything mine and here
in the first season you can kind of hear
she's not a native speaker yet though
Finley at a young i daughter Finland
Kyle later on though and this makes
sense for the character right this isn't
the actress getting better at it
it's them telling the story of the
character becoming more of a fluent
speaker of Dothraki listen to it here
if he don't you'll be Amish TV guys got
the brilliant Jen Hayden Rowell's who's
a friend and colleague is the dialect
coach for Game of Thrones
yeah that's me so she does all the
Dothraki and Valyrian that's right
and the actors do a really good job oh
they sure do Jason Momoa as Dothraki
sounds great doesn't it yeah yummy
I mean you completely by him as a native
speaker and that's a credit to the actor
for those who doesn't actually speak any
other languages besides English and I
suppose now some Dothraki Dothraki
though is much more fully developed in
terms of vocabulary you throat rip false
again gee it's got like 3,000 words I
think he/she/it throat ribs ah illyrian
has less than a thousand at this point
but it's growing to create an authentic
sounding language one needs to employ an
authentic methodology B hello today
Thank You Khan laying 5 Navi from the
movie Avatar now the P is a language
created by linguist Paul Fromer and my
life has not been the same ever since it
drew a lot of inspiration from Maori
Otilio Kitano fauna metal hoppity in
some Polynesian languages especially
when it comes to syllable structure and
you can hear that consonant vowel
consonant vowel in Navi okay - no I now
hope you've a coup but who put up that
loop of course a really obvious feature
is those glottal stops that's that sound
that's like a little catch in the throat
using English when we say oh that uh
sound you can hear it a bunch of times
in a like a pinky but oh we're not
beyond it also has a really cool class
of sounds called ejectives
which are sounds like the pop okay that
you use in beatboxing which are made by
trapping air in the vocal track instead
of breathing air out from the lungs sky
people have sent us a message so 2/3 Oh
buddy did you hear that word boop boop
boop
that in the middle isn't objective ooh
another place you hear ejectives
is actually in English when you're a
villain in a movie looked from a Jedi I
am smart and I am willing here's my
little secret I mean 20 percent don't
lie to me final Connelly syndrome or
elvish from Lord of the Rings leading
d'accord
an older year all three not the dagger
thigh syndrome which is modern elvish or
modern at the time of Lord of the Rings
this is the granddaddy of conlangs the
first con Lang ever made for a fantasy
or sci-fi story okay so we talked about
what's called a velar fricative toy
there's really similar sound it's done a
little bit forward in the mouth from
there and that's yep yep you can hear
this in German ich i ich bin ein Haley
you may not think of that as being an
English sound but say the word cute cute
cute now say it again say it slow
huge Hugh that sound right as you move
off the consonant that it's the same
sound and you can hear Arwen do it here
so cinder n' is one of the easier
conlangs to pronounce my govannen
melanine edith Nina new room it really
just consists of sounds we find in
English with the addition of cut and a
tapped or chilled
JRR Tolkien was a linguist himself were
a philologist as it's called in those
days and he made up these elvish
languages he was making new languages
even as a small child whole set of
thought he left behind hundreds of
scraps and notes when they're older and
they're modern versions which have been
compiled and analyzed my fans into what
we believe he intended to be cinder n'
combines influences from some of the
languages that Tolkien knew and loved
like finish so nice and I got Hayley I
say hey I'm Old Norse women Dinaric I
was laid up we ever of a order okay
pyramid oh also the sound system comes
kind of from Welsh Hebdo and win at the
dial and it does some things that Irish
does for the major even I can show in
Austin so Vee
go Mortensen is an American actor but he
speaks six languages my own birthday
negative a Harding hanging minute the
phone I put me Romina hit a send off
welcome on a PMO fight hola Chico Nucci
yeah I guess seven if you can't elvish
sounds really good I think it probably
came very naturally to him but yep
afternoon I'm item any date orders
okay so that's the serious stuff Lizzie
we're doin it but sometimes you don't
need a whole system you just needed to
sound convincing part to other random
stuff
Ewok YZ from Return of the Jedi yeah got
the finger okay so you probably thought
this was made up gibberish show cat so
did I even though it sounds kind of cool
it the sound designer for Return of the
Jedi we had a enormous number of alien
vocalizations and voices to create for
this film actually took inspiration from
a Mongolia clang which called cosmic
Kirsten smell bad didn't chew demo role
of minority language not very many
speakers but he liked the way it sounded
William boy Joe Joe can you could learn
her and they basically took some words
and phrases they don't mean what they
meant in that language and there's no
real grammar here but it's kind of cool
so one of the things you need for a
language is a variety of different
possible sounds otherwise there's not
much you can say
so the walking carpet fuzz ball here
doesn't actually seem to have a huge
variety of different sounds
but he does seem to be able to make
himself understood which I thought had
emotional feelings associated I'm not
exactly sure how we describe that in
terms of the human vocal tract but it's
like a uvular trill hmm just with a big
open mouth okay remember when we talked
about snake and Adam well droid anatomy
is a similar challenge for making up a
language because you don't have a vocal
tract at all but you can make beeps okay
you call me that the divine language
from Fifth Element tokimeki moccasin oh
boy p2 Molly neva Layla you can hear
that same kind of Polynesian consonant
vowel consonant vowel syllable structure
Jodi what do you mean I like it daddy
bye let me nut check this is really just
gibberish although I think they did work
out what many of the words we're
supposed to mean men alone a doctor
certainly mundo G with a lot value but
of course words alone don't make a full
language so this isn't a real con line
this is something that I didn't
understand I understand any of it but
Malkovich Malkovich from being John
Malkovich Malkovich Malkovich Malkovich
Malkovich Malkovich well we can't call
this a con line Malkovich it only has
one word in it
it does serve a kind of storytelling
effect Malkovich and sort of heightening
this meta glitch surrealism thing
Mork speak from Mork and Mindy daddy
this is Mork
no no no no no no no no no no your Howie
kind of raises and Wiggles that foul
right before the end like now that's
something that American English does
it's got a name it's called Priene nasal
tensing maybe if this were an alien
language it might be more like nanu or
nanu no no no I don't know your voices
is not right
roots peak from guardians of the galaxy
Oh so all he says is I am Groot so what
right but rocket seems to be able to
understand and borrow your group Wow
so there must be more information packed
in there our room yes said that it
probably has something to do with
inflection the music of speech it's a
tone language like Mandarin Chinese
furbish from the toy Furby do you speak
furbish da da Lola party time yeah okay
so I don't know that's one word yeah
yeah but it has the same kind of
syllable structure as Japanese does
consonant vowel consonant vowel da la
pepti pod language from the movie
arrival so there's not a lot to say
about the speech sounds linguistically
because they aren't speech sounds it's
some kind of spoken or audibly
transmitted language captive pod is a
language that has a completely different
conception of time and hepta pods appear
to have a completely different
experience of time than human beings a
stand present and future are all sort of
concurrent they're not sequential
they're circular which is why their
writing is in a circular format they
have to be able to express concepts when
they speak speak kind of all at once
linguists call this nonlinear
orthography so this is what the sound
designer came up with to represent that
oh of course I can't comment I'm not a
Hebda pod conclusion making up a whole
language from scratch
in a way that mimics a natural language
that is a whole system of sounds and
grammar and syntax and all of that but
also has the inconsistencies and
strangeness --is that natural languages
do that's an extraordinary task and the
amount of work that goes into it is just
mind-boggling so to all the creators of
these conlangs that were made up just to
enrich our entertainment and
storytelling experience
Somnath Jamari are on lebanon kiran Voss
jo qapla thank you